you want people to take your YouTube
channel seriously but you can't even
post one video a week but if you want a
strong brand if you want to be respected
if you want to build momentum these are
smart ways to position your YouTube
channel for success as you dial in these
details you're gonna be able to go
further faster and get better results
this year
seven smart ways to position your
YouTube channel for Success this year in
today's episode of the podcast we're
going to be talking about how to create
a winning YouTube strategy this year
Clarity questions to help you dial in
your YouTube marketing and branding and
also how to earn more money this year
even if you're just starting or you want
to scale your Revenue so let's dive into
this a lot of people underestimate the
power of positioning it's a really good
book it's a little bit older now but
it's called positioning and the question
is where are you positioned on YouTube
how are you positioned different
different is better than better in
business they call it a USP what is your
unique selling position and what's
powerful is that as you dial in your
unique positioning you can start to
either beat your competitors or make
your competitors irrelevant because you
have found your own unique angle to make
you a one-of-one in the marketplace
think about restaurants how are they
positioned it could be as simple as what
they do their sushi restaurant or a
Mexican restaurant how they do it is it
affordable is a little more expensive is
it fine dining and fancy there's white
tablecloth but even why they do it is in
Mission driven is there do they give a
percentage of profits away do they have
an ethic for only social uh sourcing
local ingredients there's there's
positioning that happens it's The
Branding it's their logos the same is
true on YouTube how can you increase
your success by positioning yourself on
the platform and I want to share seven
smart ways in the form of questions that
will also help you just dominate YouTube
this year overall number one is who is
your channel for
this is the positioning question who is
your channel for who is your channel not
for if you try and reach everybody you
know you end up reaching nobody
and so when you define the specific
audience that your channel is for I was
studying a lot of the Big Marketing
firms about some of the trends for this
year and one of the Trends they said is
that those who win an online business
building YouTube channels are going to
be those that go deeper in understanding
the audience they want to reach I'm
talking about knowing what communities
they're a part of knowing their problems
and Ambitions at another level knowing
who they are more than demographics
psychographics knowing what they're into
what are the other things they're
passionate about what communities are
they a part of how do they feel about
certain issues in the world in culture
who is your channel for now you might be
like Sean I think you've heard you talk
about this before this isn't new
information friend this is information
that you shouldn't even just consider
annually you should actually think about
this even monthly I am constantly asking
who who is my YouTube channel for and
practically uh you know at ethic media
we are bringing you the best tips and
tools for building your influence with
online video here on the think media
podcast we go deeper into kind of the
mindset and the strategy of really
building a high profit YouTube business
or using YouTube to scale your business
revenues and get more leads and
customers really more tactical stuff
deeper conversations like this and this
is where our video podcast lives and so
this channel is for people who even want
more deeper conversations like this and
uh this is the place where this format
is put out but here's what I did I went
to my YouTube channel on the home page
of your analytics there is an area where
you can click on the people that are
subscribed to your channel and actually
see who's subscribed now disclaimer
this box has to be checked by the person
who subscribed to allow you to see this
information I do believe that I have it
set to private so I think people
wouldn't know if think media is
subscribed to them I haven't checked
recently but I think last time I checked
so it's not necessarily an indicator an
indication whether somebody because you
might be like that's I can't believe my
friends not even subscribed to me it
doesn't mean they aren't
um it's not necessarily that information
has to be shared but here's why I bring
this up
as I went through and looked at the
people who subscribe to think media I
was actually pretty surprised
um you know we have 40 percent U.S
viewers and this is on our other channel
this is on our Tech Channel and so we
have 60 International uh viewers and
this made me really think huh how could
we better serve them a lot of the huge
there's some major channels subscribe to
us a lot of them were in Spanish or in
other languages or in other countries
that was fascinating to me as I look
through I also looked at the topics and
the niches that were subscribed many
that I wouldn't have guessed that was
subscribing to me listen the Creator who
understands the viewer best wins you
gotta go deeper this year on who is your
channel for number two what problem does
your channel solve if it's an
entertainment Channel you might solve
the problem of boredom if it's education
you might help people save money on
their taxes recover after divorce right
have more energy sleep better what
problem does your YouTube channel for
learn a new skill
be a part of a community does it solve
the problem of learning how to play
board games like the really new complex
ones uh and uh you know that are more in
depth there's there's all kinds of
niches on YouTube but being clear about
your Niche being clear about your
channel topic and being clear about the
problem here's what I learned in
business one of the things they
discovered was that the business owner
that creates a product or service that
understands the problem better than the
customer does always gets the sale and
you've probably noticed this you know
what I mean you've got a problem with
your car so you drive it in somewhere
and they go oh yeah you know it's it
looks like your timing belt's a little
bit off and this is happening too did
you even know that this was happening
and you go oh my gosh I didn't know
about any of that stuff now of course if
they're ethical in telling you the truth
and not just trying to upsell you stuff
you go wow you understand this all I
knew was it was making a horrible noise
and I was barely going and it was
puttering around
and so when somebody can come to you
where you're confused you're looking for
answers and they bring Clarity because
of their understanding it builds trust
it builds excitement so when you
understand the problems and the
Ambitions of the viewer better than even
they do like they understand what it is
but if you can articulate it put it into
words better than they do so this is why
these are smart ways to position your
YouTube channel for success as you dial
in these details you're gonna be able to
go further faster and get better results
this year
this video is brought to you by stream
yard stream yard is our go-to platform
for streaming to YouTube and Facebook
with an incredibly easy to use interface
for built-in branding transitions text
lower thirds and seamlessly bringing on
guests it really is one of the best
options when it comes to live streaming
and what's so cool is they've
implemented a brand new feature called
local recording take control of your
audio and video with local recordings by
separating out your audio and video from
your guests this feature gives you the
control over your content for later use
making it perfect for podcasts and video
creators just go to streamwoodthink.com
to get started now
number three is what promise does my
channel make to the viewer
hmm
maybe you haven't heard this one before
maybe you've never made a promise to the
viewer before this is I think one of the
biggest opportunities we have as YouTube
creators what do I mean
what I've kind of learned
that my summary of what business is is
ultimately making a promise and then
fulfilling on it
I promise that if your car doesn't run
drop it off
pay us and drive away with a car that
runs
and what breaks the cycle drop it off
pay for it
two days later it stops running no
warranty they don't back up the product
business and content creation is about
making a promise
YouTube channels they make a promise
You're gonna laugh problem is if you
don't laugh and you're a comedy channel
you might give that person a few more
tries but if they don't deliver
on the promise of the channel
then trust is reduced if you can be
consistently delivering on the promise
that you make then trust is increased
and this is ultimately what builds your
brand
ing is about consistency in Proverbs The
Book of Proverbs it talks about a good
name is rather than great riches what is
a good name it's a brand what is Nike
Nike is a name you might love Nike you
go yeah I can trust their shoes I like
their apparel I like their clothes it's
cool what is Chanel or Gucci that's a
name why is it so premium priced it's a
good name you might not care but there
are people who are willing to pay a high
price because of the name because of the
brand because it's came to mean
something because it's carrying weight
with it what does your name mean what
does your channel mean
how do you well Sean I'm just starting
that sounds like a daunting effort this
is how you build an Unstoppable YouTube
channel is you live up to the promise
you make and if you make a promise and
you keep showing up with the promise so
here's the promise on think media we're
like we're gonna bring you the best
tools and the best tips for building
your influence with YouTube and video
so the best tools so it is our
responsibility to test cameras test
lighting test setups this is also why we
hold ourselves to a rigorous standard
and we have Omar doing video production
inside of a church context Kyle is doing
audio and video production in the same
environment Omar is doing freelance
clients and shooting photography on
shoots is is in the trenches these days
I'm mainly running the business and
operationally as as a CEO of think media
but in the trenches of client work
freelance work putting cameras to the
grueling test of traveling and being in
you know in cases uh editing putting uh
editing software to the test Nolan is in
Arizona uh hammering different computers
and setups and cameras and trying this
stuff so we can pass along the answers
to you if we get a brand deal we test
the product and we make sure we actually
believe in it before we do or sign the
brand deal because our name means
everything and if our name comes to mean
they sold out or if our name comes to
mean oh you know they kind of made a
promise that it's going to be the best
tips and tools but this camera that I
purchased on thinks media's
recommendation kind of sucks
it actually isn't easy to use and they
said it would be easy to use we broke
our promise
so what I've noticed is that sometimes
people are afraid to make a promise
because it puts you it puts skin in the
game
but two that many have not made the
promise and then held themselves to the
promise to show up consistently by the
way the reason this will position your
YouTube channel for success is again
this is how you build a brand this is
how you build momentum and one of the
things you'll consistently hear about
YouTube success is you got to be
consistent but what I've learned is that
people make a mistake on what
consistency means they think it means
upload every Tuesday that's not what it
means if you upload a pile of poop every
Tuesday is that gonna succeed you might
become known for just uploading a
garbage video once a week consistency is
not just about frequency consistency is
about are you showing up with a
consistent quality of information are
you showing up with consistent energy or
you can show it showing up with a
consistent message
if you make a promise and you say come
to our restaurant and you're gonna get
sushi and then people come on their
Tuesday night date night the couple's
super excited and they sit down and
you're like all right do you want some
chips and salsa here's our menu do you
want the burritos or the enchiladas they
go what I thought this was a sushi place
I've been coming here for the last
couple of weeks and it was Sushi when
did it change to Mexican and you're like
oh sorry we're just kind of creative we
just felt like doing something different
friend do you know how many YouTube
creators do that ah I'm just kind of
creative doesn't really matter I just
kind of feel like doing something
different on my channel now listen it's
YouTube it's your tube post whatever you
want but if you want a strong brand if
you want to be respected if you want to
build momentum Nike's not open in sushi
restaurants they're making Athletic
Apparel and shoes Nike doesn't make
board games Nike you know like Nike
knows their Niche their product their
category their brand
what's yours so making a promise is also
about promising to show up
this gets a little emotional and I don't
mean to go deep and maybe bring up some
old wounds but I think about this in
like parenting you know I'm a child of
divorce and I have a great relationship
with uh all of my my parents I got my
dad and my stepdad and my mom on my side
and and the truth is though that back
when my parents got divorced when I was
three
my dad had visitation right and one of
the things you learned as a child what
does a child need from their parent they
need consistency
that if you make a promise to show up
and you don't show up the child is
crushed
and I'll admit like over the years I
have so many fond memories and and my
dad did a great job a lot in terms of
those visit visitation times but I
remember one time specifically in
Briarcrest very young standing on my
porch it was a sunny day that my dad was
going to show up to pick me up and he
didn't show
and I was absolutely crushed I remember
crying and beats being broken up because
he made a promise but he didn't follow
through on that promise I'm not trying
to throw my dad under the bus I'm trying
to call you to a higher level of
responsibility to make a promise and
then show up
you want people to take your YouTube
channel seriously but you can't even
post one video a week you want people to
take your brand seriously but you're all
over the place talking about Divergent
topics that aren't even related you want
people to take you seriously because you
went out it's a new year new me here's
what I plan on doing this year and then
two weeks later you're not even
following through in a 14-day window of
the thing you said you were gonna do
friend what promise do you need to make
and then what is your commitment level
to following through on that promise
I think that'll change everything this
year number four am I in the best Niche
or channel topic for reaching my goals
here's another way to put this do I need
to Pivot my channel topic we're talking
about smart ways to position your
channel for success I don't want to blow
up your whole world because you just
answered the first three questions and
now you're having a ton of self-doubt
but the truth is
that many businesses have understood
that the thing they even started out
doing isn't what they eventually ended
up doing they were willing to Pivot are
you willing to slightly adjust your
content strategy and the types of topics
you're covering the types of videos
you're making
are you willing to
completely change your channel topic if
you haven't heard my story I have three
Failed YouTube channels before I got to
the successful one
so even though I was committed to the
vision of YouTube is the future there's
never been more opportunity and that's
more true than ever in 2023 2.6 billion
monthly active users influencer
marketing goes up by about three billion
dollars a year with how much money's in
the industry and it's going to micro and
Nano creators the Creator economy's
valuation continues to go up YouTube
shorts are being monetized uh now on uh
as well as the traditional YouTube
Partner program there is massive
opportunity on YouTube more than ever
before so the vision of succeeding on
YouTube can be the vision the vision
doesn't change
but you may start a channel and realize
I learned a lot I wasn't quite right it
wasn't quite working and you don't
abandon the whole Vision but you might
abandon the vehicle you might say man I
was trying to get cross-country and my
car broke down you don't just go ah it's
not going to go you get on a bus you get
on a plane you buy another car you hitch
a ride you find another vehicle to get
you towards the goal and that vehicle
could be pivoting your channel topic am
I in the best channel topic for reaching
my goals you know it reminds me of uh
Johnny Law who uh was actually a part of
our video record Academy he worked with
us for a little while helping us with
brand deals and he's done a lot in his
life he's actually the most interesting
man I know um he's been in the rodeo
he's been a marine he's worked as a
police officer in the crime scene
investigation department and fast
forward to today's retired and he was
doing photography and video production
stuff and then we eventually linked up
at a Vegas influencers Meetup which side
note if you go go to
vegasinfluencers.com it was just a
waiting list at some point in 2023 we'll
do just a it's just a free Meetup that
we do in Las Vegas if you want if you're
there want to fly in I met John once and
then eventually he'd helped us with some
stuff and was part of our team here's
the point his YouTube channel was
struggling he's doing all right and he
was doing photography tips and it was
something he was good at it was
something he was passionate about but it
wasn't his ultimate sweet spot
so he had to make the decision and he
was only at a couple hundred subscribers
if he was a lot further than that he may
have wanted to start a new channel but
he had to make a decision to Pivot his
Channel or he did make that decision and
based on strategies that he had learned
inside of our video ranking Academy as
well as our Niche Finder course
he pivoted his channel
to what's now called Johnny Law he made
all of his old videos unlisted and what
he started to do was react to True Crime
cases because he's a crime scene
investigator retired so he has a unique
set of skills and a unique perspective
and boom his channel just took off he
sent me a message in 48 hours he
qualified for monetization he wasn't
even close in two days he went from zero
to 100 real quick like Drake he
ultimately uh grew to 20 000 subscribers
in a month and even Dr Phil reached out
to him which he had to turn him down he
got a chance to go on the Dr Phil show
like how do you turn down Dr Phil I mean
he was busy but uh ultimately pretty
wild all of that actually happened
because of a positioning move
he repositioned himself
I just want to ask you this could be the
key to you really experiencing
breakthrough on YouTube this year number
five do I need to update my channel
branding
and positioning that could be colors
cover Avatar who who are you showing up
as what's your personal brand what's
your look what's your feel what's your
tagline What is what is unique about you
how are you distinct What Makes You
Different
um those are all things you could ask
and then finally these first five
questions were about positioning but the
last two are all about profit
so number six is what is the best
business plan for my channel topic ways
of making money but what is the best
business plan for my channel topic if
you're in entertainment it's usually I
need a lot of views and I'm going to do
YouTube ad Revenue I'm gonna do patreon
of some kind people supporting the art
with patreon or YouTube channel
memberships I may create merch of some
kind and eventually as I build some
Financial momentum I may actually invest
in something that is even like a
consumer packaged good if you look at
Logan Paul and KSI they have their Prime
drink you look at Mr B's TS Beast burger
and he's got a chocolate bar it's not
that you would necessarily launch a
business that big but it is the fact
that as you first generate basically
seed capital and brand with your YouTube
channel as an Entertainer you think
about the other businesses you can
launch as a result on the education side
the opportunities I believe are actually
not only more but they're also more
practical you do have YouTube ad Revenue
you do have the potential to make a
channel memberships or membership
Community but in this side you can also
create online courses you also can
create coaching or events you could do a
lot of things like that one that
overlaps both are brand deals and
sponsorships and as I mentioned earlier
the dollars are actually continuing to
flood into the brand deals and
sponsorships Arena influencer marketing
last year did around I think 18 billion
dollars that's like how much money was
in the system some of that goes to
middlemen most of that goes to creators
and it goes up about three four five
billion a year and so this next year
more money is flooding into the system
how are you getting positioned now to
capitalize what's the best business plan
for your channel topic and then number
seven
am I making the videos
with the highest income producing
potential
this is one of the biggest mistakes
people make
if they want to actually go full time on
YouTube
you're making videos they may be even
getting views but they don't have the
highest income producing potential
Sean are you saying that money is
everything no that's not what I said I
did not say that at all I just said if
you want money for the mission you
should reverse engineer and think about
which type of videos would actually earn
me the most money and it's not as simple
as just getting views and doing ad
Revenue unless that's your only business
model
but what's exciting is that there are
multiple different Creator economy
business models another word we use at
think media is money plans plans of
making money and the goal is to get your
channel in alignment with the best ways
of earning Revenue like we have a lot of
creators that have small channels and
make big money but the key is you have
to have the right business plan if you
are using those strategies on a channel
where you're trying to get millions and
millions of views but you're not getting
the views it doesn't work but if you
have the right business plan and you're
only getting 16 000 views a month I'm
thinking of a Creator recently I was
talking to in our YouTube boot camp she
has multiple people working for her and
she has 16 000 views a month now that's
pretty cool but in YouTube that's like a
rounding error like in the YouTube World
16 000 views is a incredibly small
number yes she has a incredibly
profitable business built around her
Channel this is answering the question
am I making the videos with the highest
income producing potential if you love
the think media podcast what really
would bless my heart if you would just
take a minute or two to leave a review
on Apple podcasts about your feelings on
the podcast even if you watch it on
YouTube opening up Apple you're like
Sean I don't even have an account okay
fine but if you specifically use apple
that's kind of a big Hub obviously of
the audio side of this podcast leaving a
review would be huge and I would uh love
you forever and then additionally I know
wherever you watch this give me some
feedback even some topics for a future
episode you'd love uh to hear about
maybe a guest or a topic you'd love
covered hit like button and subscribe
for more
foreign